the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alright we're we're back so I think we
just went over just for the tour some of
the more complicated analytics that
people can do and now we're going to
show some examples of not those specific
analytics but using the reuters data set
that we had before some of the Analects
that we can do here so again and this is
in the d 4m api we go into the examples
directory its apps and now we're going
to deal with tracks and this is this is
the data set here the data actually this
entity dot Matt was actually created in
the previous this entity analysis
actually creates this enemy on maps the
same same file so we just have over here
and so let's get started and just to
remind people we do load entity Matt see
we have this e here that's the data it
represents essentially almost 10,000
documents and 3600 entities in that if
we do spy y dot transpose
better okay and so there you go that is
the entire data set against pipe lot
very useful tool for for doing that so
you can see we have locations and people
and times in this data set we also have
organizations in here you can zoom in on
that we want to you know you can see
these are the locations and then the
organizations and people seem a little
bit more actually look at the actual
values here and you see there's this
calm popular location here what is that
as the United States yes the United
States does appear a lot in Reuters
documents as one expect what do we think
this one is here any guesses what yeah
your see it's already there New York gah
yes we can read all right organizations
anything really popular here and maybe
this guy is he popular International Red
Cross right and people here we don't
have any really popular people in this
list Ahmad Shah Massoud I have no idea
who that person was back in nineteen
ninety six anyway so that's the data and
you see by the way when every single
time you click because we when we when
we make those spy plots I have to makes
do some compression on the strings just
to make it work and but I we actually
always print out out to the screen the
full exact string so like i want that
string you can just then copy it if you
want to say copy and paste it or
something like that or the full person
or something like that you can then copy
that and paste that you know do
something like that like II this this
guy get in there show that's all the
documents that contain this person's
name and then this shows the character
position I believe that they appeared in
the document so again have all kinds of
fun at
oh that just all those rows past those
rows back and let's say it starts with C
here how about organization everyone
correct my spelling here i'm going to
type this from organisation and / all
right there we go and yeah I always get
that wrong stars with starts with same
area all right there you go so this
shows you all the organizations that are
cited in the documents that contain this
person's name you know and you see how
it kind of and this is kind of the
spirit of it right i mean it's like just
oh I want that I can get that oh it can
then that could then say all right we'll
give me you know and you could just keep
going and going and going you know if I
did rcv you know of that right it would
now return those as triples so are those
are all the documents see those are all
the columns the there we go you get it
you get the idea so again very very
powerful type of syntax there all right
so I just give you a sense of the data
set that we're looking at so let's look
at the first example here so we're going
to do track analytic build test this is
going to build some tracks out of this
data so i have these documents and they
have locations in them and people and
times so i could say hey if there's a
person and a location and a time in a
document you know maybe i could call
that sort of a track right so let's do
that so what do we do here so the first
thing we do is we loaded the data the
string values are those character
positions we don't really care about
those so we're going to just get rid of
them and just convert it to numeric like
we like we've always been doing here and
then I'm going to say my thing that I
want to track is going to be anything
starting with person so I said that and
my time thing is going to be anything
starting the time and my location thing
is going to be anything here starting
with location so I've done the starts
with me to get
ranges and now the first thing I'm going
to do is I want to limit my data to only
rose the contain that have at least one
of all three of those so I'm not dealing
with I have a person and a location and
no time what are so I'm just going to
clean that up so basically I get all the
people and I some that I I basically a
sum sum all the sum across the the
column so I basically compress the
columns and then I some the rose all
right there we go some of those I get
then all three then i filtered them back
out and that just reduces this to the
ones that contain just the ones that
that have these um let's see here so now
I want to collapse these into I want to
create essentially just want to get
edges and times so i can do that with
the call to type syntax and the valta
calls and texts and going pop back and
bopping back and forth between that so i
get a set of edges the edge list which
is essentially the document and and the
time and now i'm going to combine these
back together into a new associative
array which is essentially still has the
same text label ed you know which is
essentially the document but it has
columns of time and the value is space
all right then I'm going to do another
one which is again same as a row which
is the document or the edge and it has a
column of space and a value of time and
now I can construct a track from this
through this wonderful marks sparse
matrix multiply so essentially I
transpose etx and then I'm going to just
get the people then convert those
numeric values and then we do this cat
value mole which will actually convert
that so and I can also these are time
tracks and these are spaced tracks and
again it's a little difficult to explain
to you
exactly why this works why these matrix
multiplies give us the answer that we're
going for because you're going to have
to like sit and think about the actual
matrices this is a great example to go
do and then explore these various
associative arrays to actually see why
these matrix multiplies actually give us
the answer that we want so in fact we
can take a look at those so I'm look at
31 here so this shows us basically and I
plotted the transpose of this but so we
have basically the people all right and
then these are times and so basically
for each row here I have a listing of
times than if i click on one of them it
will give me a location okay in fact I
think that number is the number of times
that appears so basically we have here
the person daniel Smith was in a
document with a timestamp of 1996
November twelfth oh that's almost
yesterday and then and then and then the
location New York appeared once in that
here's another one and so so this is a
track of sorts we basically have a
person and set a times and a set of
tracks that's one kind of track another
kind of track here's now we have person
and locations so that was the other
matrix multiply we did and so now we
have person Carole King location Buffalo
and on this on this time so those are
two different ways of representing the
tracks obviously these are triples but
then you can use either these matrices
to do additional queries and other types
of things all right so that just shows
you how using matrix multiplies other
types of things you can construct more
sophisticated graphs or data structures
in this case tracks which is very
interesting type of thing let's move on
to the next one that's going to
ta to so there's a slightly more
sophisticated track builder again
someone I read read the data in I create
my three sort of categories here the
sort of the object and the time and the
location or the coordinate and then I
have a function here called fine tracks
which actually just goes and creates
those tracks that I essentially did in
the last last section to be honest with
you the reason I did that is because
some of those matrix multiplies used to
be really really slow and so I did a
sort of special function that took
advantage of certain parts of property
to the data to make it find these tracks
much a faster eventually I broke down
and just optimize the matrix multiply
and so now that in the past when I ran
that last query before it would have
taken like a minute to actually run the
analytic you know which got which got
annoying so I optimized it but we still
have this code this code is you know
another shows all kinds of little chick
tricks and techniques for doing things
that are you know slightly better and
using triples instead of associated
raise if you want to do optimization so
we leave it here but but the matrix
multiply performance is now pretty good
that these these tricks are less
necessary so we want to do here we have
this track now and I want to do a track
query so I have a person here michael
chang another person Javier Sanchez now
Michael Chang was a tennis player at
this time was heavier Sanchez also a
tennis player at this time no I think
there was a hobby or Sanchez losing
tennis player at that time so we just
want to look we're going to just do
essentially here a and just say give me
of this of this track and say give me
give me the listings for for these two
these two people p 1 p 2 and then we use
our display full command to sort of make
them in a nice neat tabular format and
you see here basically here is Xavier
Sanchez's listing okay and here's
Michael Chang's and you see there's no
overlap here we don't ever
have them in the same time or same place
we can also do things like track windows
so we can say I want to set a time range
here and a location Australia so if we
have our track thing here and I say
alright give me the time range tea and
then equal to to all locations Australia
this shows me all tracks that
essentially went through this location
in this time window and these are the
different folks that they list they live
Sanchez Melissa Russo whoever that was
michael chang and michelle martin so
those are just an example of a more
sophisticated analytic and here we're
using the fact that for our associate of
arrays ok we actually have defined
equals equals so this only works though
if X is a constant so it will check the
value to see if that value if it's a
string if it's equal to that string or
it's a numeric value if it's equal to
that to that numeric value but only
works with a constant one could argue
that maybe I should make this work for a
list of of strings but then the matlab
syntax doesn't really work there either
if I have a matrix equals equal to a
list of I don't know I don't know if
that really works so we try and preserve
the matlab sintex where weekend and
again we're then we're just getting the
columns again this thing returns an
associative rate is equal equals it
returns the associative array of all
things that are equal to that and then
we can look at their columns alright
moving on here next one is ta three so
those are fairly simple track builders
let's begin to do something that's I
think kind of you could imagine you know
doing that track analytic one could
imagine doing that with existing
techniques that are out there existing
tools and stuff like that it would be
long you would write a lot of code to do
it but you could you could def you could
do it now let's do some things where
you'd like wow this is
really something that it would just be
prohibitively complicated to do it using
other techniques alright so once again
we load our data we convert it to
numeric we get our object and our time
and our space keys we find our tracks
and then we've built something called
fine track graph alright and this is
actually not that complicated but it is
more than like one or two lines but what
it does it says okay I have this track
this track is a sequence of locations
okay in a particular time order well now
I want to build a graph that's location
by location so if a track started in one
location and then when its next
destination was another you know that
will of course that create a new graph
okay so I now have a new graph which is
essentially 220 x 220 locations okay and
we can actually take a look at that and
that's this graph here so this basically
says you know there was a track that
started in Belgium and then its next
stop was Albania where here's another
one it started in Australia and in
Colombia and obviously we have a dense
diagonal here because of you know by
definition well actually a lot of times
they just that's just the way it works
and so again here's Damascus Florida all
this type of things so now we've created
a new graph of these tracks all right
now we can do something like a track
pattern so let's say I just want to look
at the tracks associated with people
associated with the organization
International Monetary Fund so I'm going
to do I'm going to start with person ok
and I'm going to limit my data so i have
my
I'm going to basically limit it to data
that begins with the organizational now
I'm building a new graph G 0 ok fine
track graph of just that data set so
basically taken my a which is this graph
I said oh just go back and find me the
people associated with the International
Monetary Fund and now I can do things
like all right because this this track
graph the value is the number of times
that occurred so for instance if I say
show me now all edges that occurred more
than twice all right and where the
tracks that were due to people associate
the International Monetary Fund we r
greater than twenty percent of all the
tracks that occurred so basically I'm
looking for something to happen more
than twice in that you know IMF folks
did more than twice and of all the data
the IMF people did it you know a lot of
the time so we're in a lot of people was
just a really really popular track and
so we see here now we get karachi and
afghanistan so we had essentially at
least two of those and all of them were
people associated with the IM IMF
Afghanistan Britain here's Britain in
England well obviously that's a little
bit kind of written and England or the
same thing right as certain person hears
islamabad as la mode Moscow Moscow so
this just shows you the kinds of things
that you can that you can do with with
typing again this is a very
sophisticated type of analytic you were
to try and do this things using existing
types of things if you knew this was the
analytic to do when someone handed the
student said go implement it using
another technique you definitely could
do it but discovering the analytic using
existing techniques would be very very
time-consuming and this is this kind of
tools very very easy for you to explore
and get the analog just right and i
would say that in certain sense what d
forum is doing here is doing the same
rule that we've always used matlab for
in single signal processing people use
it to play with their algorithms to
figure
out there algorithms get their
algorithms right let me know this will
give us the right answer and then when
they deploy it and actually make it part
of a real system sometimes they'll just
take the matlab code and make it a part
of the real system but more often than
not the target system or the target
application will require you to port it
to some other language maybe C++ maybe
Java on for for deployment reasons we
still see that happening today that you
know algorithm development is one thing
deployment is another thing even if
people use the same language for doing
algorithm mental and employment using
the deployment people end up having to
completely rewrite with the algorithm
analysts wrote anyway because the
algorithm analysts had a certain things
they were concerned about and the
deployment person will have completely
different issues that they have to worry
about but I think d firm allows you to
still do that same kind of model on
these new types of data very very and a
very useful and productive way and sort
of get the productivity that we want out
of that all right and I think let's see
here so finally one last thing a more
complicated Anna lick which I call sort
of a multiple hypotheses tracker
essentially what we're doing here is
we're loading the data we're going to
just focus on one person here all right
and then the locations are you know it
specified by time I mean that the time
is specified by the time column and
location specified location and then I'm
going to have this function called
modifying multiply hypothesis track
trackers for michael chang with respect
to the dataset e and what this does is
this says all right in the previous
thing i was basically just making kind
of one pic you know if I had a document
and Michael Chang was in it and there
was multiple locations and times I would
just sort of pick one of those locations
and times here I'm now going to show you
for michael chang for each document all
the locations and times so here's
basically you know africa and time and
let's
see here maybe we can make this a little
smaller probably help a bit a little
smaller there we go you can barely see
that but you see here so this basically
shows all the times all the locations
and this shows you you know essentially
the full in theory the true track could
be going through any any one of these
there's there's multiple doors into a
single track really for michael chang
there's multiple potential tracks and
then this complex value I happen store
here just because I'm using commas is
the first one is the character distance
the location is to the solar michael
chang appears in a particular word
position in the documents and it tells
me that austria appears 278 characters
before him and that the time stamp
appears 11 characters before his name
and so over here you see the time stamp
appears this is a different document and
it appears I you know but with a certain
team same time the chill appears in a
different different locations so you can
then use this data to actually go back
and say you know what I only want I want
to pick the words that are closest to
michael chang and i want that to
actually be the real track for the firm
michael chang so that just shows you
kind of the more complicated things that
we can do with that so with that that
leads us to the end of the of the
examples and um there's any question to
be happy to take them now we're sending
all right good i'm just showing you some
of the kinds of things that people can
do and so